sapete ragazzi viene data c'è un motivo
se io faccio le introd e video accesso
perché i video sono una merda no non è
per quello e perché sia anche per quello
però non sempre quello perché quando io
molto i video li monto la mattina e io
la mattina tutte le mattine dopo una una
certa devo andare a cagare siccome il
tempo tutto il tempo libero che una
mattina lo utilizzo per montare video
l'unico momento che ho per fare la intro
del video e quando sono accesso e quindi
io faccio le il processo giovani oggi e
black wade che è un gioco di barche gran
gioco un grosso di barche che ho fatto
in compagnia di anima questo che era
stato fatto sul canale di fascia qualche
settimana fa però questa che state
vedendo la mia visione delle cose quindi
vi lascio al video bene a tutti e marie
benvenuti questo 9 abbiamo trovato
questo gioco che è la vita della vita
cioè non avesse capito se vai sei
personaggi per cambiarti di percorrere
la pelle di continuo lorenzo sono uscito
al corsa cento quello che sei
aspetta che prenderebbe grosso aiuto e
arrivo ecco tiso dietro il testo di
studenti al designer a salve signor
capitano e brutti sembra berlusconi
suonava il pianoforte
stiamo affondando ma dai parlate di
berlusconi stiamo affondando ma perché
aiuta lascia all'arrembaggio su naturale
centrale a gas sono molto york dai
boschi le sono morto stiamo affondando
sa cha cha cha siamo durati mosaici
addio una nave a per il vestito dieci
uomini
oggi in cui prendere i secchi e buttare
via bellissimo tutta l'acqua giu ma che
cos'è
salve signor capitano ascoltare
carichiamo i cannoni per le prossime
beffa di vedere cosa c'è di sopra
sono curioso che buttiamo dentro abbiamo
vinto non arrivarono essere i pirati o
no noi siamo gli australiani che ho
perso
bella la ragazza che ha visto io tifavo
per lei guarda se molti sasha dai
australia subito vuoi avere nominato
come capitano si mia auto nomino di alla
tua crew perché dovresti essere un buon
capitano via gli immigrati dalle barche
che anima vorrebbe essere capitano
perché mi piace la pasta io via gli
immigrati dalle barche ma perché è che
la dedica di quantica capodanno a napoli
va bene ok avete operative di pirati io
sono davanti sulla punta tuttava bordo
per l'italia
spariamo non li ho presi neanche per
sbaglio dalla giunta giu no ci stanno
facendo bene ma cosa secolo ci lasciano
un progetto cioè solo facendo va via
gerry non affrontando se la marca
secondo un altro marchio che ci ha fatto
disperare o stavolta serie c'è un'altra
giornata non è di tutti i suoi cannoni
tutti 6 carboni rivoglio carichi marinai
trovava sotto è pieno di gente zio
nostra si si è più di gente nostra hai
preso presa presa presa casalinga dopo
questa voce andrea bravi a fare il film
i pirati dei caraibi subito dopo
siamo apertissimi e ovvio che ciò che
ora manca la presa presenti abbiamo
vinto di jolo pirate smos l'abbiamo
buttata giù così per ci voglio credere
mai dobbiamo andare sulla barca
affettare la spada mufasa tieni la palla
è bellissimo quando ti aspetta guarda in
alto mare in alto
dica come in archi la schiena essere un
piacere occhio malocchio occhio separati
cerchiamo veloci arca vacca come il
nostro capitano è morto come me abbiamo
vinto da un giocatore va bene va bene va
bene
giuseppe giuseppe adesso dai da bere a
dani vieni via con me ascolta ma i
cannoni sono equipaggiati tutti giusto
si e gli occhi chiusi
insomma quasi la vera aspettavo e ho
capito che ci sono non ci sono mica vado
riuscirci come si sa ci sta se uno sta
salendo sua entrato dove davvero è vero
pato narciso brutto ma basta è morto
basta sasha nave poverino cannoni pronti
ce l'abbiamo buono e giusto che un altro
incredibile dopo il fido tantissimo
proprio
a occhio
occhio che pare non questi bravo bordo
malaga ma chi mi chiama ci si può anche
[Musica]
marco momento ha vinto qui alla barca
come come aiuto sta arrivando un'altra
nave la prendo la prendo la prendo al
volo
sono salito su un'altra nave a caso ma
quella dietro cece esser preso sempre
alleata
io non ho capito come mi son trovato
fuori mentre sparava a caso di quanti
serate g20 di quasi di qua mi sono
cagato è vero vero occhio fuoco che non
se la morte non ci sono ma lui ha ucciso
ovvio che se rivendica bar cadenza days
adesso è andata giù anche era buttata
giù non soffro qualcuno l'ha buttata giù
non c'è oggi sul capitano la fine ucciso
grandi lei e lei è sempre la migliore
per me sempre ultimi ma con stile e
quindi i ragazzi dopo tutto questo io
ancora sono qui però va bene resterà
black wade che a me personalmente piace
da morire e bellissimo che c'è un botto
sto gioco 50.000 lights dovrebbero
d'episodi su black wade non perché
secondo me è fighissimo se non ci
arriviamo
patrizio piaciuto momento mi piace anche
vari stato è condizione in questo
momento questo non c'e la descrizione
però si sa che ci vediamo prossimo video
[Musica]